Are we going to allow AI to decide
who lives and who dies? If we can't
even draw the line there and say that no
we're not going to allow AI to be built
to anonymously murder anybody then who are we
kidding if we think we're going to be able to
exclude any uses of AI! We've already seen real
world use cases of these weapons types and we're
seeing reports of development and use of these
weapons at an accelerating rate. So we decided
to make a film to illustrate very clearly that
the issue is you make these autonomous weapons
you can launch them by the million or the 10
million and wipe out entire human populations,
quite deliberately, and that makes as much sense
as selling nuclear weapons in a supermarket.
So the film is structured in three parts. The
first part of the film is to remind us of the
risks of these types of weapons and to illustrate
the end point that we are rapidly driving towards
with today's technological developments. What we
see there is a world in which autonomous weapons
have proliferated outside of military hands and
into the hands of non-state actors, civilians,
and police forces alike. The second part of the
film talks about the rhetoric and the thinking
and the technological developments that we're
already seeing today that are driving us towards
that end point with autonomous weapons. And the
third part of the film aims to show us what can
we do about this, how can we mitigate this risk by
acting today, and that is based on the real world
policy proposal that has been outlined by the ICRC
by the red cross and that is slated to be debated
by the UN at a meeting later this December. And
this part of the film aims to be hopeful. It
aims to show us that we can still act to mitigate
this risk we can draw a red line on a prohibition
of autonomous weapon systems that are designed
or used to target people. It also shows us that
we can set a powerful precedent by steering AI
in a direction towards safe and ethical use.
My name is Stuart Russell i'm a professor of
computer science at the University of California
Berkeley. I've been doing artificial intelligence
for more than 40 years. I'm Max Tegmark,
a professor doing AI research at MIT and also the
president and one of the founders of the Future
Life Institute. Hi I'm Dr. Emilia Javorsky and I
am a physician a scientist and an entrepreneur.
I believe that artificial intelligence
can help life flourish like never before
if the wisdom with which we manage it grows faster
than its power. Now the key to having this huge
upside from artificial intelligence is going to be
to make sure that we don't pervert this technology
into destabilizing stupid uses. I feel
a particular responsibility to make sure
that AI is used for good and banning
autonomous weapons is one of the best
things we can do to make sure that happens.
I work with the Future of Life Institute,
which is a non-profit organization focused on
mitigating the risks of powerful technologies.
Over the past few years I have been
leading our efforts on the topic of
lethal autonomous weapon systems. That's why I'm
so excited to share with you if human: kill().
We are live with Brett Hauer on the line where
police are now confirming a drive-by shooting
at a polling station. They're all in a line shot
in the head just where they stood. The whole line
is dead! The line is dead? Looks like some voters
had children with them. All spared, not even hurt.
Brett local PD are saying a suspicious device may
have been discovered. Could this be slaughterbots?
I see police, I see some officers deploying
camouflage masks right now. We're on the move.
Police are interested in an abandoned vehicle.
They're heavily camouflage now. Wait,
there's, there's another vehicle and
another vehicle across the street they
seem quite concerned about that! Look out!
The cops are down, Erin. This is devastating.
Yet another national security
crisis for this administration.
Everybody was dancing and
then suddenly we heard...
Horrible...
The world in which we fail to draw a red line
on autonomous weapons means that the types of
things we see and hear in part one of this film
will be really imminently upon us. Here clearly
one political party has decided that by attacking
pole lines in areas that the other political party
dominates they can scare people away from the
polls and win elections that way. We're already
seeing drug cartels using remotely controlled
drones to assassinate members of opposing cartels.
It's very likely that they would use these weapons
if they were widely manufactured and available,
they would use these weapons to carry out their
their campaigns of terror against the military
against the police against civilian populations
and against each other. This scene highlights
that lethal tolerance weapons are a weapon of
mass destruction in that it enables very few to
kill very many. Because they don't require human
supervision to carry out the attack. If you wanted
to use a million remotely piloted drones to kill
everyone in Afghanistan, you would need a million
pilots and another 15 million support personnel
to manage all those weapons. But, with fully
autonomous weapons, with slaughterbots, you only
need one or two people to define the mission
and release the weapons. People who think we can
avoid immoral things being done with slaughterbots
by putting in some sort of ethics chip into it
forget that the person who determines what's
morally good and morally bad is the owner of the
slaughterbot who will, might decide that everybody
with this skin color is bad and should be killed.
Robots have no moral conscious of their own,
they'll just do exactly as they're told. The
technology is able to overcome the countermeasures
used by the police, which are special camouflage
masks to hide the fact that they're human beings,
but the slaughterbots seem to be able to evade
this countermeasure actually to recognize the
police as targets even though they're wearing the
camouflage masks. So this points to the fact that
these weapons can evolve very quickly to defeat
counter measures. They can be reprogrammed because
it's only a software question it's not a matter of
redesigning the hardware so you can reprogram them
overnight to defeat a countermeasure. The tech
that was used in the slaughterbots in this scene
had three components: the targeting, the killing,
and the flying. The flying is just trivial quite
a little quadcopter GPS control. The killing, it's
very easy to do with a very low weight explosive,
for example. The targeting is something you
already have in your smartphone where you
it looks at you and unlocks because it recognizes
your face. It's quite easy to use face recognition
to instead just say hey is this a child that we
should spare or is it an adult we should kill.
Maybe you look at the skin color of the person
and use that to decide who you're going to kill.
The autonomous weapon operates a bit like a chess
program, which decides where to move the pieces
and which of the enemy pieces to kill. So it's not
a mysterious spooky emergent consciousness thing.
It's the same type of autonomy that our
chess programs and Go programs and other
game playing programs have had for decades.
All the tech needed for this already exists
and it's just a matter of integrating it and mass
producing it. I think the number one reason why
lethal autonomous weapons haven't already been
banned is just a bunch of misconceptions about
what they are. On many occasions national
governments and senior defense officials have
talked about the only problem with autonomous
weapons is what happens if they become
conscious and decide that they hate human beings
and start killing us at random, right. I've talked
to senior defense officials who literally said
that they have talked to their expert advisors
and they've been assured that SkyNet the conscious
computer system that directed the terminators
in the terminator films that SkyNet is not a
real possibility and so we don't need to worry
about any of these bad scenarios. The German
government said that a weapon is not autonomous
unless it is fully self-aware. So, when you have
defense officials and governments talking complete
nonsense about a subject of such international
importance we felt that we had failed.
The word "lethal" in "lethal autonomous
weapons" means that they kill humans. So
an automatic anti-aircraft missile for example or
anti-tank missile is not a lethal weapon because
it shoots at a tank and an aircraft and a lethal
autonomous weapon will only kill people that are
not sitting inside of tanks that are just walking
around doing their thing. That's why their dream
come true for criminals and terrorists who want
to wipe out a certain ethnic group, say. The
word "autonomous" in "lethal autonomous weapons"
means that it's the algorithm itself that decides
who lives and who dies, which means that cruise
missiles for instance are not lethal autonomous
weapons and nor are the drones that are remote
controlled because in both cases the decision
about what the target is made by a human being.
And finally, many people think of terminator
or some sort of two-legged robot when they think
about lethal weapons, which is pretty useless
from a military point of view. But what's much
more popular in its effectiveness are flying
things in swarms or alone, little things like
you'll see in our film and various other types
of embodiments that look absolutely nothing
like a two-legged Arnold Schwarzenegger.
No, no, no... killer robots marching
down the street that can't happen
these are professional munitions and they
aren't just gonna fall into the hands of
bad guys. We're building really robust procedures.
Whole constellation of products at the trade show
this year. This is an industry energized by last
year's successes. Devices apparently hunted down
and killed soldiers who were regrouping after
fleeing the battlefield. Of course they can't
target kids in the street. They are hard coded to
target men in the battle space. Surely you mean
men and women? Well, sure. Women can be added
to the target profile. Purely a military device
for confronting military aggression. Nobody
is endorsing civilian applications.The second
such autonomous assassination of leading
scientists... Big win for regional powers,
as they hope to cripple their
neighbor's nuclear program.
The design obstacles are dropping like
dominoes. We are getting more lethal,
more versatile, more affordable, so we can empower
more customers. Regime change without the billion
dollar spend or the body bags. A real lift to
the smallest armies. Legitimate armies though?
Well, sure, but who are we to decide who they
are? The second section of this film is really
aimed to mirror what we're seeing happening
today. Now these might seem a little over
the top and exaggerated, but this is modeled on
the real world rhetoric that we've even heard
in our discussions with diplomats and people who
are in favor of developing these types of weapons.
This idea that, "Don't worry we'll build robust
verification procedures. Yes, proliferation is an
issue and escalation is an issue, but we'll deal
with that when the time comes." So i've heard the
argument that autonomous weapons won't fall into
the hands of the bad guys. It's like saying well
let's build machine guns and of course criminals
will never ever get access to machine guns,
crime gangs will never have them. But
we know for a fact that that's not true.
Proliferation is pretty much inevitable when you
have weapons that are really cheap and really
small. For example, the United States simply
lost 200,000 AR-15 automatic rifles in Iraq.
They have no idea where they went. There are a
hundred million Kalashnikovs in private hands.
The STM Kargu drone which is produced by a
government-owned corporation in Turkey was sold
to one of the factions in the Libya conflict
despite the presence of a very strict United
Nations arms embargo. So in fact there appears to
be very few controls if any on the proliferation
of these weapons. So the way this would work is
that arms manufacturers produce large quantities
of weapons.They go to trade fairs all over
the world, many of them completely unregulated
or taking place in countries like North Korea or
Syria where there are really no controls on who
gets what, and then arms dealers buy them. They
pass from through shell companies to drug gangs,
to human smugglers, to factions fighting
in civil wars, to terrorist groups,
and all of these groups are extremely well armed
and you can be absolutely sure that they are
not manufacturing those weapons by themselves.
Slaughterbots is just a tiny fraction of all the
militarily useful things you can do with AI
weapons so the arms industry will be just
fine if you ban them but if we don't ban them of
course they're going to sell those too. The only
reason they wouldn't is if they're illegal, like
bioweapons The balance of power is an interesting
question in this debate. Do we want to tip the
balance of power away from the major powers
who have long histories of learning to abide
by constraints on the use of military power
and tip the balance in favor of rogue nations,
non-state actors who are able to act in ways that
are completely unconstrained by moral or political
or economic consequences of their actions?
I think it's inevitable that the development
of these weapons would reduce international
security for pretty much every country. They're
largely effective as weapons of attack and not as
weapons of defense. The particular concern that
I have is the small anti-personnel weapon the
so-called swarm weapon which could be extremely
effective not just against for example infantry
formations but also against human populations,
civilian populations. Autonomous weapons in many
ways make ideal tools for assassination. You can
be hundreds of miles away when the attack takes
place. It can be completely unattributable and all
the security measures that are currently taken for
example to protect political figures would be
useless because you don't require line of sight,
you don't have to have somebody with a sniper
rifle hold up in a hotel that has direct line
of sight to the politician. So, I know for a fact
that the fear of assassination is uppermost in the
minds of many governments as they think about the
risks of autonomous weapons and we only have to
think back to world war one which was precipitated
by the assassination of Archduke Ferdinand
that once you get into tit-for-tat
assassinations and politicians
you can very quickly devolve
into a full-scale war.
I think another important point is that delegating
the decision to kill humans to an algorithm
is a deliberate devaluing of human life. The
people that i've spoken to in the military
take that responsibility extremely seriously
and handing it over to an algorithm and saying,
"I can't be bothered to worry about it i'm not
going to put myself at risk we're just going
to have the algorithm do all the killing"
is a complete abdication of responsibility
and puts the value of human life far lower
than it should be. The other idea that
we could just have wars where only robots
die doesn't really make sense at all.
If you could prosecute a war and win
without any human casualties on either side
then you might as well play baseball or
tiddlywinks to decide who wins the war.
In a real war, one side only surrenders when the
amount of damage inflicted on their populations,
their control infrastructure, their um their
factories, their cities, becomes unsustainable
and that's true whether the damage is being
inflicted by robots or by human soldiers. So
another one of the big concerns about autonomous
weapons is accidental escalation of warfare.
So if you have fully autonomous
defense systems that can retaliate
against what is perceived as an attack then
you could imagine this happening even without
a real attack. On several occasions in
the history of nuclear weapons for example
our early detection systems have detected a
nuclear attack that wasn't actually happening.
It was only human intervention that prevented
a full-scale nuclear war from taking place.
The reason that we chose to make if human: kill()
was to pick up where Slaughterbots one left off.
Slaughterbots one warned us of an emerging risk
that we were going to face. When we presented
Slaughterbots at the CCW in 2017, many people
dismissed it as science fiction. For example,
the Russian ambassador said, "why are we even
discussing this? This is 25 or 30 years in the
future. It's just science fiction." But when
we presented it to people in the AI community,
as they were watching the CEO demonstrating the
weapon and talking about its use for mass attacks
the AI researchers thought that this was a real
video, not a fictional presentation. But, this was
a real recording of a real CEO. So they obviously
considered the technology to be entirely feasible.
Meanwhile, a Turkish company called STM was
preparing the public announcement for their weapon
the Kargu autonomous dronel, which was announced
about three weeks after we presented the video
and advertised as having the capability for
autonomous hits using face recognition and
human tracking. Kargu drones from the Turkish STM
company were used in Libya to hunt down fleeing
humans according to a United Nations report and
we just don't know whether these were soldiers or
whether they were some random Libyan truck drivers
that had been contracted or what. And then the
company obviously is not sharing any information
with us. At the time, a lot of people were like,
"ah forget it they're decades and
decades away!" Well, they were wrong
because now they're already here. And
so the next part of the story for us
was to talk about what is the kind of thinking
that is fueling our development of these weapons
and moving towards that horrific endpoint
that was shown in Slaughterbots one,
but more importantly what is it that we can do
about it to avert that outcome? And how can we
really take this opportunity of autonomous weapons
not only to avert a really dire outcome for
humanity but also help steer AI and set a powerful
precedent for how AI can be used for good and be
used safely and ethically. And this idea of a red
line and drawing a red line as a global community
that machines must never decide who lives and who
dies is really a first step in that direction.
All right now we're going to cross the UN where
we're told the treaty has now been signed.
Generations before us thought that future
wars would be fought with toxic chemicals
and infectious germs. They thought our landscapes
would be littered with unexploded landlines
and more recently it seemed inevitable
we were on a course to mass produce a
new class of merciless autonomous weapons
which use algorithms to decide who to kill.
We knew the dangers but we
thought we had no choice.
Because we thought our enemies were too
inhuman to respect innocent lives. We thought
if we didn't, they would.
But each time we feared the worst,
we were wrong. Together our nations have
ratified a new legally binding treaty. Together,
we prohibit weapons which select human
targets and attack without human control.
Humanity must prevail on the
battlefield, and from today it will.
So the third section of the film at its most
literal level is a fictionalized version of
the real world policy proposal for autonomous
weapons that is currently being debated. And so
that's at the heart of what the fictionalized
secretary general is saying in in this speech,
is imagining what would our world look like on
the day that we actually agreed to a treaty on
autonomous weapons. So in this last scene we see
the drone come in and is looming overhead and
given all we've experienced up until this point
we assume that it's going to make the decision
of who to kill of these two humans locked in this
complex standoff. But, it doesn't, it de-escalates
the situation and both people make it out alive.
To me the drone represents our hopeful future with
technology where it is used not to undermine our
humanity, but to build on it and to advance it.
In the earlier parts of the film, we see human
beings through the lens of technology as code,
in screens, and through cameras but in this part
of the film we revert to a cinematic style of
filmmaking to really illuminate the human element
and to know that human beings are not just sensor
data, we're human beings. And in this scene we see
a tense standoff between two individuals who are
trying to navigate the complexity of one another's
humanity in impossible circumstances of war.
And what this scene really says to me and
what we see in the trade-offs and the dynamics
between these two individuals is that there are
certain elements of being human and navigating
the humanity of another that will never be a
capability of an algorithm or of a machine.
We start out with "if human: kill()" and we end at
"if human: protect()". The kill-protect dichotomy
is really representative of the options that lie
before us for our future with AI. There are very
few outcomes to be imagined where our future with
AI is incremental or middle of the road. It's
either going to be one which is flourishing and
incredible and advances our humanity or one that
is very dark and destabilizing and undermines it.
And so this is the decision that's before us today
here with autonomous weapons is the first
step, which one are we going to choose to kill
or to protect? If we can't even agree that we
don't want to let people legally build and sell
AI systems that can on their own go off and
decide who to kill and kill them, I mean,
who are we kidding that we're ever going to
draw the line anywhere, right? Whereas if we
can win that battle, we've set the precedent
that there are some things that are off limits
and we can steer this amazing technology towards
a future that I think we will all be really really
excited to find ourselves in. So this film is
really timely in that while it's a work of fiction
it's something that is illuminating
a very very real world and applied
circumstances that we're chatting through today.
It also is helping us to ground in what's ahead
and as we think towards global action on this
issue we have this amazing opportunity, which is a
once in five-year meeting of the UN in December to
debate this issue specifically. And we have this
incredible moment in which we can draw this red
line and mitigate this risk of autonomous weapons
and so that for us was key in developing this
film was we wanted to be able to remind people
that this risk is here and but there's still
something we can do about it if we act now.
So the policy prescription for autonomous
weapons, there is a great piece that has
been put forth by the ICRC, which is the
International Committee of the Red Cross.
It's an independent organization and they're
largely seen as the custodians of the law of war.
And their policy proposal has three pillars.
The first being a prohibition, a legally
binding prohibition that's important on systems
with high degrees of unpredictable behavior.
The second, which is the policy proposal
that we explore in the film, is a legally
binding prohibition on autonomous weapons
that are designed or used to target humans.
And the last one is the need to develop
regulations on other types of autonomous
weapons. So you can think of that class as sort
of an autonomous fighter jet against autonomous
fighter jet where the target is not actually a
human being. And these three pillars are to be
debated by the UN at the meeting in December
as to whether or not to act and take these up.
So a key element of a policy prescription for a
lethal autonomous weapons in this ICRC position is
the idea of a legally binding instrument, right.
Legally binding means new law, a new treaty. Now
this is important because that does not mean
a political declaration or a political promise
or some strong statement. There really is when we
look throughout the history of disarmament affairs
no more important tool than a legally binding
instrument in order to exert a real meaningful
effect on the behavior of states and also
generating a diplomatic and social stigma
around a class of weapons. We've seen this before
with land mines, we've seen it with bio weapons,
with chemical weapons. Legally binding is
central to whatever sort of path forward we take.
So there are plenty of historical examples
of where legally binding treaties were used
to mitigate the risks of powerful technologies,
the bioweapons ban, the chemical weapons ban,
bans on blinding lasers, the list goes on.
The bioweapons ban in particular is one that
we really see as a great example for the future
with autonomous weapons. The bioweapons ban took
the weaponization of biology and germ warfare off
of the table and that unlocked biology as a field
to be one that we associate with new medicines,
curing diseases, and transforming agriculture.
That's the fate that we hope a new legally binding
instrument will have for artificial intelligence.
By avoiding its weaponization, we will unlock its
positive potential to steer us towards a similarly
flourishing future for the science. The argument
that autonomous weapons have a high degree of
military effectiveness and therefore no one's
going to agree to ban them probably isn't true.
Chemical weapons were quite effective in World War
I. If you read the memoir of the Russian gentleman
who was in charge of a large part of their
biological weapons program in the 60s, 70s, 80s
he believes that Russian use of
biological weapons in World War II was
extremely important in helping to defeat the
Germans. And so there's no doubt that the US and
Russia believed biological weapons were a very
very important part of their defense programs.
And yet, we were able to ban them.
The argument that was used initially
in the US by biologists and chemists was that
if these weapons become widely available,
they will be cheap effective weapons of mass
destruction that will proliferate to non-state
actors, to rogue nations, to smaller
countries, and tip the balance of power
away from the major powers and thereby
reducing the security of the United States.
That argument was persuasive to Richard Nixon who
unilaterally abandoned the US biological weapons
program not because it was ineffective but because
it would become effective and if that happened
would reduce the security of the
United States. So are we doomed,
right? Is our fate sealed with autonomous weapons
and we should all just invest in a bunker? Now
there's many reasons why you may sincerely want to
invest in a bunker, but I sincerely believe that
autonomous weapons should not be one of them.
And so with this film we really aim to show
that yes action is possible, this is what it could
look like, and this is why we need to do it now.
So what is it that you can do about autonomous
weapons? Learn more about it. You can find out
more by going to autonomousweapons.org. If you
want a future free of slaughterbots please share
this film on social media and please make sure
that the people who are going to be making these
decisions actually understand how much you care
about this because this is an incredibly important
watershed. And try to move your country your
fellow citizens in the direction of supporting
a treaty. If you are a journalist, you have
an enormous opportunity to actually influence
what happens to get the happy ending we saw in
this film. The main reason that this hasn't been
solved already is because these perspectives are
almost never made available to the broader public
and therefore the decision makers never hear
from the broader public about the need to
actually do something about it. If you are a
person who works in artificial intelligence
you should know that the vast majority of your
colleagues already support this idea of banning
lethal autonomous weapons. We've done a lot of
work at FLI to develop both open letters and
pledges to never develop or work on these systems
and to support the kind of regulation that is
being put forth by the ICRC. So please make your
voice heard and don't let a few rotten eggs you
know ruin the reputation of your field for you.
The same way that biologists stood up and said
hey we want biology to stand for saving lives,
make sure that your field gets remembered as
a field that helps find new solutions, not the
field that kind of ruined our open society with
slaughterbots. And if you're a member of the
diplomatic community it's time to act it's time
to adopt these types of policy frameworks that
are clear, that are concise, and that are ready to
go. And so encouraging bold action from our policy
makers is really what the world needs today. So at
present the topic of autonomous weapons is being
discussed at the CCW in Geneva. The CCW process
is a consensus process so it requires essentially
every nation to go along with an agreement to
have a discussion, to go along with drafting the
terms of a treaty, and to agree to the treaty.
An alternative is the UN general assembly which
doesn't require unanimity and I think that would
reflect better the interests of the people
of the world who over and over again in polls
have shown that they are very strongly opposed
to the development of these kinds of weapons.
If you are part of the United Nations CCW
process then please vote "no" in December
to any extension of the CCW's mandate beyond
this year unless there's a clear resolution
to ban lethal autonomous weapons. Otherwise,
the CCW is not part of the solution it's just
standing in the way of the solution preventing
this issue from going to a different forum
that can actually handle it and give us the
ban that we need. Steering the future of
technology is hard but it's worth doing because
the upside if we get it right is just tremendous.